seba her touch has come with her lawyer
to find out how her husband human rights
activist or honk image angus is doing
the couple were arrested at an airport
after turkey declared a state of
emergency and he remains in custody it
gives awesome listen they told us we
were arresting you it was clear they
were enjoying it they took us away
without any explanation they didn't even
have an arrest warrant Hena Daniels
Athena alunos and I appreciate so allow
me to iowa turkish President Recep type
air dhawan feels threatened by people
like her tush and her husband especially
since July fifteenth when soldiers
attempted a coup they occupy TV stations
and ministries blocked off bridges and
attacked the seat of parliament and heir
to one's home more than 300 people were
killed the coup attempt was soon quelled
and the suspected plotters arrested
they'd been accused of working for
muslim preacher Fethullah Gulen since
then the country has been swept by a
wave of arrests targeting all government
critics seba her tush says her husband
once defended a newspaper affiliated
with the Gulen movement in court that's
enough to warrant suspicion from the
Turkish government demolished a llama on
either there's no evidence that he
supports Gulen as a lawyer he fights for
everyone's human rights doll my little
pigs in there yet unleash didn't give it
up at this
seba ritesh's husband has been in
custody for 48 hours neither she nor her
lawyer have been allowed to talk to him
that's a clear breach of law says Ali
coach butanol tight yet I be seen a
Vista New Zealand yuxin Galactic Council
and the government can't just do
whatever it wants during this state of
emergency no matter if it lasts 36 or
however many months and then just say
everything will return to normal no it
must observe the law now even when it
comes to the coup plotters otherwise
it's no better than them chef children
it'll be a while until turkey goes back
to normal busloads of people are being
transported across the country to face
prosecution the atmosphere is tense
meanwhile air21 supporters back this
tough stance they think the 13,000
arrests are justified
we care a lot of people demand that
those who have damaged this country
received the punishment they deserve
look all the shops are open and life
goes on as normal despite the state of
emergency after hours of waiting sibel
her tush finally learns that her husband
has appeared before a judge so she heads
to court but yet again her husband is
not released he sent back to jail
without having spoken to her or his
lawyer even once after four days or honk
image Angus is finally released sibel
her tush doesn't want to talk about the
anxiety and fear she felt during this
time she's glad her husband wasn't
abused during his incarceration there
was a very tense atmosphere I saw some
people they were severally beaten they
even couldn't open their eyes of course
this coup plotters should be prosecuted
and should be punished but this doesn't
mean that this kind of Investigation
gives a green card to government or
prosecutors to include human rights
defenders lobbyists journalists into
this basket this is devon take the
second thing this never gives a green
light to torture anyone or interest
anyone only a few media outlets most of
them foreign reported on Genesis arrest
and his wife's fight to free him most
Turkish newspapers shied away from the
topic preferring not to address the
government's heavy-handed crackdown